Let's now dig into the developer operations section.
So we'll have quite a lot of in-depth information
pointing you to the correct areas of either documentation
or tools that you might be able to use when working
with HMI in your projects.
So the first tool we want to go over today
is the sometimes you'll see it be referred to as UAT,
but it's essentially the Unreal Automation Tool.
So the automation tool is a host program
and a set of utility libraries you
can use to script unattended processes relating
to Unreal Engine when using C Sharp.
So internally, we use the UAT for a variety of tasks,
including building and cooking and running games.
You can run automation tests and script other operations that
can be executed on your build farm.
So the source code for the automation tool
and various scripts that run it can be found in your project
in the Engine Source Programs Automation Tool.
So you just want to go to where your Unreal Engine is installed,
go to Engine Source Programs Automation Tool,
and you can find that there.
So the automation system is built
on top of a functional testing framework, which
is designed to do gameplay level testing, which
works by performing one or more automation tests.
So the more tests that are written,
there may be more functional in nature,
either low level core or editor tests that need to be written.
You can use the automation framework system for these.
So the test can be written, broken down
into different categories, depending on their purpose.
So you might have a unit test or a feature test or a smoke test.
You may have heard these phrases before.
You can even do things like screenshot comparisons.
But if you do want to dig into this deeper,
there again is great documentation.
It's the testing and optimization
section of the documentation.
And there you can dig into exactly what the UAT is
and how to use it in your own projects.
We've also got continuous integration
and continuous deployment.
So as part of a packaging process,
which we'll dig into a little bit later here,
the automation tool can be used for this.
And it's used to work through a set of utility scripts
for manipulating Unreal Engine projects.
So for the packaging process, the automation tool
uses a particular command called build cook run.
And this command can cook content from a platform,
package it into the platform's native format for distribution,
and then deploys it to a device.
And it can automatically run the project where you want it to.
So packaging your project doesn't solely
require the use of the UAT.
But you can use it from the File menu
to select the available platforms or the command line
to cook and package the content for a platform.
So when we look at Gauntlet, Gauntlet
is a framework to run things and validate results.
It's specifically designed.
It's not limited to this, but for running Unreal sessions
on a variety of platforms.
So an Unreal session is all the processes
needed to execute a game with Unreal Engine.
So you may have a multiplayer game
that requires four clients and a server.
You can use Gauntlet for that.
And then Jenkins is an automation.
Jenkins in relation to automation is recommended.
So you can combine it with the P4 plugin
to manage the data, the P4 being the Perforce plugin.
And you can build a trigger for automatically building
your game.
So a few good documentation pages to follow here as well.
You've got Launching Unreal Engine Projects on Devices,
which is a great documentation page.
We've got Packaging and Cooking Games in Unreal Engine.
And we've also got Build Operations, Cooking,
Packaging, Deploying, and Running Projects
in Unreal Engine, which are all useful documentation pages
to look into more.
When we look at the hardware considerations of our projects,
we want to know about the GPU versus CPU utilization.
We want to know what background processes are going on based
on the setup of any kind of specific vehicle hardware.
We've got resolution scaling for optimization,
depending on what screen we're using.
We want to measure the performance available on Vulkan
but not OpenGL.
And you can also have device profiles,
which you can customize the rendering settings
on a per hardware basis.
You can do all this in the project files, in config,
default device profiles, any.
So in your Windows Explorer, just
go to your config folder of your project,
and you can find the default device profiles there.
When you're working with multiple people in your team,
this is good for solo development as well,
but especially so when you're working in teams,
we want some kind of version control.
So version control helps prevent conflict resolution
and asset locking.
So it's almost like a library system
where you can lock a file, take it out,
use it without someone else editing that same file.
So GitHub alone is not good source control.
We have a few options here.
You've also got the multi-user editing
plug-in on local network.
But however you want to approach team development or solo
development, it's definitely advisable to use version
control.
So again, some good documentation here.
Using source control in Unreal Engine
is a good documentation page, and also the multi-user editing
in Unreal Engine is a really good documentation hub.
When we look at using Unreal Engine source,
you can grab that from GitHub.
You just need to connect your Unreal Engine account for this,
and you can just set up the menus and the connections here.
And then we also want to install Visual Studio to build
the source files from Unreal Engine.
So no matter which source control software
you end up using, the manner in which you interface
with that software from inside of Unreal is the same.
So the following guides that I'm about to say
will detail everything you need to know about source control
in Unreal Engine.
So we have development setup building in Unreal Engine
on the production side.
We've also got just a source control in.
If you go to the production pipeline setting
in Unreal documentation, that's a really good place to start.
So just production pipelines.
And then there's a source control specific area
in there, which you can see has in editor, per force,
and SVN documentation.
So that's a really good place to start
learning about how you might integrate the engine code,
but also just source control into your projects.
And when we look at the Make AAR,
Make AAR versus the Android application,
where we should use UE's library.
So the Make AAR generates an AAR,
which is the engine wrapped into an AAR
and provides a Java-based API to initialize control at runtime.
It sends data to and from the engine via blueprints.
So the engine visualizes essentially
any of the visuals from the engine
are injected into the graphics library context
for the Android Surface View.
So basically, Make AAR integrates Unreal Engine
into existing Android apps to render on your Surface View.
So normally, Unreal would be its own application
when you package it.
But if you want to run Unreal inside of an Android Studio
project using something like Surface View Target,
or you want Unreal to be the full screen application,
you don't need to use Make AAR.
And when we're looking at cross-compiling here,
we can compile Windows to Linux.
And also the Mac native compiling.
So cross-compiling makes it possible for developers
to target Linux from Windows.
And at this time, cross-compiling is only
supported for Windows and Mac users.
You currently have to the results of the native compiling.
Additionally, we do support test and provide libraries
and tool chains for Linux x86 on the 64 platform.
And if you do want to look at the documentation page,
that's sharing and releasing with Linux
in the native tool chain.
So since Unreal 4.0, and so if you're using Unreal Engine 5
and onwards, the setup shell automatically
downloads the tool chain, which generates to your computer
and links with the code bases.
So the native tool chain, you can then
compile against a fixed SYS root, the system root.
And if you wanted to compile something on Ubuntu 1804,
you'll be able to start the binary on the CentOS 7 there.